the corona virus pandemic, although very much
under control and much of the world, my friends
touring, Belgium, France, a lot of different
countries.
Things are you know, everybody's
wearing masks on public transit, but it's
a very normal life.
It is not under control here in the United
States.
In fact, it's spiraling completely out of
control.
Dr. Anthony Fauci said about a month ago we
could be heading towards 100000 new cases
per day, sounded, according to some hyperbolic
at the time.
Doesn't seem like it.
And what were originally only spiking cases
are now starting to be spikes and hospitalizations
and spikes in deaths.
And in fact, yesterday, July 21st, we had
the most deaths in a day dating all the way
back to the 2nd of June.
OK, 50 days, the highest death toll in 50
days.
Yesterday, tragically, hospitalizations have
re surge to essentially the highest point
we've had.
We're close to the hospitalization peak of
mid-April.
Of course, we have this lag time where first
U.S. cases, then you see hospitalizations,
then you
see deaths.
And that is exactly what we are seeing.
There were some people saying the death surge
isn't going to come.
Most deaths in 50 days, 51 days yesterday.
So we're in a race against time here.
We're in a race against time when it comes
to a treatment and a vaccine.
to removing Donald Trump and putting someone
there who will just say doctors need to deal
with this, not politicians, but because we've
failed to deal with this.
We have much less time than other countries
do.
Hospitals are filling back up.
Deaths are creeping up.
I see use in Florida, Texas, other hot spots
are anecdotally reporting being at capacity
or close to capacity.
Our ability to maintain a lower mortality
rate depends on keeping icy use open with
space available, hospitals with space available.
Many states
have that, and that's great.
Many states tragically do not.
And the top hot spots continue to be California,
Texas, Florida, Arizona.
Georgia's now a bigger and bigger piece of
the problem.
Tennessee, the growth rate in Idaho is very,
very high, even though the case numbers themselves
are not yet that high.
The Carolinas, Oklahoma and Louisiana, Missouri,
Mississippi, Alabama, I mean, it's it's bad
in a lot of the country.
And when we look at this, not state by state,
but by county, looking at the map that we
have up on the screen for our video audience,
we see that there are these large swaths where
things are under control at the county level
and those are mostly in the northeast and
then in the mountain time zone area.
But then a ton of orange and red colored counties
on the map where cases are not under
control and are getting worse.
There's a term I don't know that this is really
a term I I'm not saying I created this, but
I've been using it.
I haven't heard other people use it.
It's sort of virus escaped.
Velocity, escape velocity, the idea of the
force required to escape the gravitational
pull of the earth for a craft that is trying
to exit Earth's gravitational pull.
We are very close to getting to virus escape
velocity and escape velocity.
When applied to the bite virus would be the
point at which the cases are growing so quickly
that even if you immediately shut everything
down like a full lock, people don't.
You know, I'm talking like an authoritarian
lockdown.
Even there you would continue to see a dramatic
spike because there's just so much so much
virus out there and incubating if we aren't
already there in
some of these states that are hot spots.
We are very close.
And the situation by August 15th could be
unconscionable is the word.
I would apply to it now.
This is optional.
I really want people to remember that Italy
was hit early as a hotspot, but is completely
under control right now.
And life is returning very much to normal
there.
Switzerland was hit later for people who say,
well, if you were hit earlier, you're under
control.
But the U.S. was hit later.
Switzerland was hit later than Italy.
They are also completely under control.
So at this point, this has been going on long
enough, five months, five plus months.
The first cases we know, we're actually in
late December in the U.S.
But, you know, in a serious way, we're talking
about five months.
This is no longer about getting hit earlier
or getting hit
later.
It's now policy.
It takes about 10 weeks to flatten and attack
the curve.
If you do it right, we're five months in every
country now has had the chance.
Many have done it.
We are every day building the pandemic.
People are desperate to get back to normal.
So my.
Well, everybody's got to put a mask on.
You've got to stop the indoor events.
You've actually got to do the work required
to do it.
And I'm horrified, horrified by where we might
be in 20 days.
I hope I'm wrong.
So far, unfortunately, if anything, I've been
I've been too optimistic.
In other words.
I was thinking, you know, by June one, June
fifteen, we're going to have very few cases.
That's the way the models are looking.
Well, we we just it was a disaster.
People didn't do what we were supposed to
do.
We
didn't have that law.
And we may be heading full speed ahead into
an even bigger it's not even a second wave,
just an even bigger continuation directly
into the fall and flu season.
So we'll be polling our audience on our Instagram
page, which is David Pakman show about what
you're doing and what you expect in the fall.
So make sure you're following us there.
And we will be back with much more right after
this.